it's been more than a decade since the
September 11th attacks the question is
whether we're on this pendulum and we're
swinging we're gonna swing back towards
some sort of semblance of sanity when it
comes to civil liberties hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Ryan Devereaux of the
intercept comm he and Jeremy Scahill
have just published a fantastic and
deeply disturbing article about a watch
listing guidance document this is a 166
page document published last year by the
government that talks about how do they
figure out who is a suspected or known
terrorist
there are 19 agencies that this document
apparently goes out to how did you come
across this document and how did you
decide to bring it to life through our
sort of conversations with the
government we are 100% convinced of the
authenticity of the document published
by the National Counterterrorism Center
which is responsible for sort of
consolidating the nation's terrorism
information and this is for domestic as
well as foreign what types of people end
up being watch listed and then put on
either a suspected or known terrorist
list the Muslim communities of the
United States have really important the
brunt of these sorts of initiatives so
often times more often not you know
those are the those are the kinds of
folks that are targeted the way these
this guidance is written though it's
it's broad enough that wide wide
categories of people dissidents
protesters activists all could be caught
up in this system the no-fly list in
2006 under under Bush it had peaked to
about 44,000 people and the following
year Department of Justice Inspector
General issued this scathing report and
the government began cutting down the
no-fly list and this meant these were
44,000 people when they showed up at an
airport they're not getting honorable
exactly exactly into or out out of the
United States 2009 that list had
actually been pared down to about 4,000
people according to New York Times
reporting but then December 25th
Nigerian man
Martha Abdulmutallab the underwear
bomber got on a plane to Detroit nearly
succeeded in detonating a bomb in his
underwear which sort of triggered the
guidance that there
published Obama put all of this pressure
on the watch listening to community to
start ramping up their collection of
information he loosened the standards
loosened the rules the end the criteria
for bringing people into the list
because the watch listing community was
complaining that you know it's we
couldn't put Abdulmutallab on the no-fly
list we because of the restrictions are
in place so Obama loosened those credits
and one of the most striking quotes that
you guys highlight in your in your
article at the intercept concrete facts
are not necessary so what does that mean
the whole sort of watch listing
structure turns on reasonable suspicion
and it's I'm sure you know reasonable
suspicion is this sort of highly
controversial standard that comes up in
lots of issues surrounding policing stop
and frisk and that sort of thing so this
low standard is what is necessary to you
know an analyst needs to have reasonable
suspicion that a person is engaged in
the this broad range of terrorist
activity or associated with somebody who
might be engaged in that sort of thing
because also we have to keep in mind
that we're talking about known or
suspected terrorists so these these are
people who are essentially the way this
document structures that are people who
are suspected of being suspects talk a
little bit about how you get off of
whether it's the no-fly list or these
these suspect list because the article
goes into that is it an easy process or
is it at all clear process it's it's
completely an unclear process it's all
done internally basically if you want if
you believe that you're on the list you
can submit a form through the Department
of Homeland Security and it all goes on
internally and you're never informed
even if they take you off they never
tell you that they took you luck they
never tell you in the first girl you say
that you're you know that you're on you
never know so they have these things
called nominations right nomination is
sort of how you get on one of the lists
and you know the agency that is
responsible for that is the nominating
agency let's say it's the FBI the FBI
nominates you to be on a list now you
have and it's accepted now you have a
file with your information if another
agency say the CIA finds more
information about you they can update
your file right but now they are also
nominating
agency with a link to your record if the
FBI decides hey we should take this guy
off the list then they put in that
request but CIA has to agree with them
so when these agencies start sharing
information on individual people they
all have a responsibility for that file
so all of these agencies now have to
agree with one another with the Snowden
revelations and then reporting before
that I mean basically what's happened is
that every kind of paranoiacs fantasy
has come true that you know well the
government really is doing sorts of
things with supercomputers that we did
not really think it was doing or were
possible is exposure in the press enough
to actually turn back any of this kind
of stuff or is it that this is just
going to be the new the new future where
the government is constantly surveilling
us and we just learn to live with it and
work around it that's the question that
we're facing right now it's been more
than a decade since the September 11th
attacks but the question is whether
we're on this pendulum and we're
swinging we're gonna swing back towards
some sort of semblance of sanity when it
comes to civil liberties and I don't
know we might still be swinging away
from you if you look at you know some of
the extensions of Bushehr programs and
initiatives under Obama you get the
sense that maybe we're not yes I it's
not a pendulum it's just that both legs
just had Natalie yeah it could it could
be but then again you know over the last
year with the Snowden revelations I
think that there there is reason to
believe that the tide might be changing
the government is taking in so much data
that it actually really can't find the
people it's looking for and is that
starting is that a place where there
might be resistance from within the
Intelligence Agency to reverse some of
these policies yeah I mean I think
that's a great point and one that gets
overlooked often because when we talk
about things like the watch list the
no-fly list you know you can obviously
make the civil liberties argument and
many people do and and they they should
but there's also an efficacy argument to
be made and for years and years this
system has been criticized from within
internally in 2012 the GAO issued this
report based on interviews with people
from the watch listening community these
are intelligence officials
counterterrorism officials were saying
we're drowning in information here we
this is making it harder for us to do
our job it's ridiculous it's in its
policy driven it's not about doing
actual
investigations it's about looking like
you're doing something so there's
security theater within the intelligence
community as well as projected outward
citizens exactly well we'll leave it
there I want to thank Ryan Devereaux who
along with Jeremy Scahill at the
intercept comm published a absolute
must-read story about a watch listing
guidance document from the government
that explains who gets on watch lists
and why Ryan thanks for talking to us
thanks family for reason TV I'm Nicol sp